the pay gut then exists in so a lot of  things where there's a lot of male  actors who will be like I will not uh  sign on to this contract unless I know  my female counterparts are being paid  the same and so I think the pay Gap then  comes and well it's also the truth it's  also the trait like disagreeable though  so as women like we're naturally more  agreeable 100 so so we're I'm more I'm  terrible at negotiating I just want to  make everyone happy and I just want to  be like yeah I'll do whatever for  nothing and  um and but that's like men are more  disagreeable if you look at the  agreeability scale does that make sense  yeah yeah so again like why do we just  assume patriarchy when you don't know if  it's because of different personality  traits and gender differences